today on the matte wall show tax-funded
npr publishes a lengthy investigation
into the racial implications of the
emojis that you use when you text people
it sounds crazy already but wait until
you hear some of this it's pretty great
also trans activists were planning a big
protest at my event at texas a m last
night so what happened i'll tell you
about it plus polls show that viewers
are fleeing the nfl because of its
political pandering big surprise there
plus a pastor attracts the ire of the
mob for promoting modesty and we know
pastors aren't supposed to do that and
adele gets in trouble herself for saying
that she loves being a woman which we
know now is transphobic in our daily
cancellation one of my opponents on that
dr phil episode appeared on his podcast
yesterday to uh offer her reflections on
the experience that it turns out that
she doesn't like me very much we'll talk
about that as well and so much more on
the matte wall show
[Music]
you know 40 years ago ronald reagan saw
massive inflation unlike anything the
country had ever seen before until today
in reagan's own words inflation is a is
as violent as a mugger as frightening as
an armed robber and as deadly as a
hitman right now your retirement
accounts are under attack thanks to the
inflationary policies of this
administration
uh which means that uh your future is at
stake it means that we're all vulnerable
and you got to do something about it and
here's something you can do you can call
birch gold if you have not yet called
birch gold the only people i trust to
help you diversify your 401ks and iras
into gold then you're missing the boat
and uh actually you're you know you're
basically treading water you're out in
the water by yourself in the ocean
without a life vest birch gold has your
life vest let them help you convert an
ira or 401k into a tax sheltered ira in
gold with thousands of satisfied
customers and an a plus rating with the
better business bureau you can trust
birch gold to protect your savings text
walsh
298-9898 to get a free info kit on gold
reagan knew the biggest threat to our
wealth protect yours now text walsh to
989898 to get your free info kit now
so you know npr like most of our
corporate media institutions has been
for years deteriorating irrevocably into
far left lunacy the only difference
difference between npr and most other
media institutions is that npr is funded
by tax money of course you are you are
paying to facilitate this dissent
whether you like it or not
and so it's it's worth taking a look to
see just how bad things have gotten
and what i'm about to share with you is
a reflection of both our media's total
intellectual bankruptcy and also of the
left's rapidly increasing derangement
all of that is present in this one story
and also i share it with you because
well it's just really funny
a viral article posted on npr.org
yesterday has this headline
which skin color emoji should you use
the answer can be more complex than you
think
now you should know by the way that this
dissertation on emojis of color
has three authors
three people were needed to write this
thing and their names are asthma khalid
alejandra marquez john say
and patrick
jaren watten anand
so they took all the people with the
hardest names to pronounce and they said
we need you on the emoji story and they
all contributed to this article about
the about the complexities of emoji skin
tones
this is a subject that i confess i have
not thought
about
at all really mostly because i'm not
insane also because i don't use emojis
because i am a literate adult
human and i prefer to communicate using
actual words which is i i wish that most
other adults would join me in that
because through the rampant use of
emojis we have as a society essentially
reverted back to caveman days scribbling
pictures on the virtual cave wall to
convey our emotions rather than you know
using written language to communicate
that we're happy or sad
instead we dumbly draw a smiley face or
a frowny face i happy smiley face which
is what you're really saying when you
send a smiley face so all of this
controversy over emoji color could be
avoided if everyone simply behaved and
communicated as adults and used actual
words rather than little pictures and
cartoons
in any case um let's go to the article
it's it's everything that you're hoping
it will be
and so much more
so it uh it begins
heath rossella identifies as
three-quarters white and one-quarter
filipino
well hold on a second he identifies as
that or he is that
because if he is that then we don't need
to know that he identifies as that
this is like if you asked me where i
live and i said oh i identify as living
in nashville
that's going to leave you with more
questions than answers about my actual
physical residence
um because if i live there i don't need
to say that i identify as living there
of course that's the point though of
this identifies as qualifier and it's
why you're seeing it applied to it
started with gender and now they apply
it to so many other things because it
makes everything obscure and confusing
and weirdly subjective
anyway
it says when texting he chooses a yellow
emoji instead of a skin tone option
because he feels it doesn't represent
any specific ethnicity or color he
doesn't want people to view his text in
a particular way he wants to go with
what he sees as the neutral option and
focus on the message
quote i present as very pale very
light-skinned
and if i use the white emoji i feel like
i'm betraying the part of myself that's
filipino
but if i use a darker color emoji which
maybe more closely matches what i see
when i look at my whole family it's not
what the world sees and people tend to
judge that
i should remind you by the way because
you might lose sight of this none of
this is meant to be a joke
this man who worries that he is
betraying himself and his ancestors
by using a certain color emoji it's not
a joke this is something he's really
worried about and you should respect his
struggle and his anxiety
this is a major tax-funded once
respected news organization
and an article authored by three
journalists
which which begins with some random
guy's anxiety related to the color of
the thumbs up emojis that he uses when
texting people
now he says that um he goes with the
yellow option because it's race neutral
apparently having no concern for the
fact that it appropriates from the
you know
jaundiced community
meanwhile other people feel obliged to
find a skin tone which matches and
represents them
npr says continuing
in 2015 five skin tone options became
available for hand gesture emojis in
addition to the default simpsons like
yellow
choosing one can be a simple texting
shortcut for some but for others it
opens a complex conversation about race
and
identity quote i use the brown one that
matches me said sarai cole an opera
singer in germany
i have some friends who use the brown
ones too but they're not brown
themselves this confuses me
where do they even find these people
where are you finding the the opera
singer in germany to talk about emojis
but it is very confusing she says so you
know i'm also confused when someone uses
a perfectly round cartoon smiley face
when they themselves do not have a
perfectly round cartoon face
yesterday someone texted me a smiley
face and i said wait what is this who is
this supposed to be this looks nothing
like you what happened to your face
what's going on dear god
this is a totally normal and healthy
response to this situation
let's keep reading
cole is originally from california and
identifies as black and american
hold on
cole is originally from california and
identifies as black and an american
descendant of slavery
so that's another thing you can identify
as i suppose now
you can identify as being a descendant
of slavery
when a lot of victim points for yourself
that way
she said that while she was not offended
when a non-brown friend used a dark
emoji she would like to understand why
quote i think it would be nice if it's
their default but if they're just using
it with me or other brown people i would
want to look into that deeper and know
why they're doing that she said
okay so according to cole if you don't
identify as black or brown
you can use a darker emoji but only if
it's your default so whenever you want
to text an emoji to your black friend
make sure to include a screenshot of a
previous emoji that you texted to a
non-black friend so they can run a
comparison and see that you're using the
same emoji for everybody
because remember they might want to look
deeper into it
and this again is totally normal
who has not received an emoji from
somebody and felt a desire to embark on
a thorough investigation
into
the emoji their motivations for sending
the emoji their history of emoji usage
we've all been there shortly
continuing a 2018 study published by the
university of edinburgh
looked at the use of different skin tone
emojis
what it referred to as modified emojis
on twitter to find out if the modifiers
contributed to self-representation
alexander robertson an emoji researcher
at google and phd candidate involved in
the study
said the emoji modifiers were used
widely but it was people with darker
skin who used them in higher proportions
and more often
instead some white people may stick with
the yellow emoji because they don't want
to assert their privilege by adding a
light-skinned emoji to a text or to take
advantage of something that was created
to represent diversity
perhaps like heath rossella they simply
don't want to think about how their
message can be interpreted but zara
rahman a researcher and writer in berlin
argues that the skin tone emojis make
white people confront their race as
people of color often have to do for
example she shared sarai cole's
confusion when someone who is white uses
a brown emoji so she asked some friends
about it okay
you know what i i take back everything i
ever said
about college
see i had thought
i had thought that people were wasting
years of their lives and hundreds of
dollars
hundreds of thousands of dollars rather
of their parents money most likely for
pointless degrees and utterly useless
fields but now that i know phd
candidates are becoming emoji
researchers
i've changed my mind
because we think about this for a second
here guys if we don't have universities
who is going to prepare the next
generation of emoji researchers
if we don't have phds there's not going
to be anyone around to research emojis
and the next time someone says we've got
a bunch of emojis here we need to have
them researched
who's going to do it i can't do it i'm
not i don't have a college education
wrapping up the article it says rahman
said there was a default in society to
associate whiteness with being raceless
and the emojis gave white people an
option to make their race explicit
quote i completely hear some people are
just exhausted from having to do that
many people of color have to do that
every day and are confronted with race
every day ramen said but for many white
people they've been able to ignore it
whether that's subconsciously or
consciously their whole lives
rahman admits there's no specific answer
to all the questions about emoji use but
said it was an opportunity to think
about how people want to represent their
identities
i think it's more one of those places
where we just have to think about who we
are and how we want to represent our
identities she said and maybe
it does change depending on the season
depending on the context
so
if you didn't believe that white people
have advantages in society
hopefully you've been disabused of that
notion
because because
if you think if you're white you think
you have no advantage think about your
emoji privilege
have you ever even thought about that
you probably haven't
because you're not a slobbering lunatic
so i think we see two things in this
article
um well three things
the first is that npr should be defunded
and
after it's defunded should be launched
directly into the sun
keep in mind by the way that again we
fund npr we fund pbs
um
and this this has this state of affairs
has continued even while republicans are
in charge of the government they have
decided they're going to keep on sending
money to these as well as to the baby
killers of planned parenthood by the way
um so that's the first thing the second
is that
powerful forces in our society
and yes npr counts as a powerful force
unfortunately major media institution
funded by the government
and forces our society are very invested
in making sure that you experience this
kind of insane incoherent
totally needless racial anxiety
they want you to know that every moment
or they want you to think anyway that
every moment
everything you do everything you say
everything you think every interaction
in your life no matter how seemingly
innocuous is completely fraught with
racial implications
they are trying to create racial tension
where it doesn't exist
that's the kind of
sinister underpinning of even something
as stupid and admittedly hilarious as
this npr article about emojis
they
they
are going to people who who actually
in their in their everyday life in
reality
experience no almost no racial tension
at all there's like there's no problem
they're just living their lives
and whether they're black white whatever
race there are doesn't really come up it
doesn't create any problems for them
and so you have to go looking for the
problems
and looking quite desperately
picking up every single rock looking
under every rock looking in every
crevice and corner to find something and
then they find it with emojis
and finally this brings us back in a
very neat and symmetrical way i think to
our first show of the week uh where i
talked about my recent experience in a
third world country
where we were last week
and people there as i said you know they
as
comes as no surprise they live in shacks
made of spare sheet metal they drink
water tainted by sewage they watch their
children starve and die from preventable
diseases i mean they live
um quite horrifying lives
of profound suffering
and this is not just a small minority of
people living this way in the world this
in fact is how most people live in the
world
and it's how most people in history have
lived
so we here in the west in our comfort
and luxury we are we are in a small and
privileged minority no matter what your
race is
um and we live now in obscene uh
unprecedented comfort and luxury
and now decadence
and rather than be grateful for that and
appreciate it
and say to our own ancestors and the
people who built this country well geez
thank thanks for thanks for this
you know thanks for establishing this
civilization this country
where you know i can live in a home with
air conditioning
and i can do things like turn on my
faucet
and drink the water
which that alone you want to talk about
privilege that alone compared to how
most people live is an enormous
privilege
rather than be grateful for it and say
thank you
um we go looking for problems
and some of us live lives so devoid of
actual problems that we have to become
as desperate as this
making a problem out of emojis
and that perhaps tells you everything
you need to know about western culture
and especially about npr
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
well if you've been to the pump recently
which i'm sure you have you uh i don't
need to tell you that gas prices are
ridiculously high and the prices of
everything are ridiculously high right
now which means that you got to look for
any opportunity to save money and here's
one get upside my listeners are earning
cash back for every gallon of gas every
time they fill up all you have to do is
download the get upside app in the app
store or google play right now and it's
very simple you're using promo code
walsh for 25 cents per gallon or more on
your first fill up cash back
don't pay full price of the pump anymore
get cash back using get upside all you
got to do is download the free app use
promo code walls for 25 cents per gallon
or more on your first tank um and i've
talked to people who drive a lot and
they're making as much as 200 300 a year
in cash back and if you're thinking
there must be some kind of catch there's
got to be red tape to this thing what's
the fine print there's no catch the cash
is added right back to your account you
can cash out any time to your bank
account paypal you can get an e gift
card to amazon and it's as simple as
that as easy as that it's free money why
not take it just download the free get
upside app and use promo code walsh to
get 25 cents per gallon or more cash
back on your first tank that's code
walsh
well to begin with uh you heard about
the texas of my texas a m
event last night um a speech that
was supposed to be infiltrated by by the
left and you know we had their whole
written out plan that we uh that i
shared with you and it was it was a
pretty interesting plan was a good plan
you know they had it all they had all
written out they're gonna sneak in they
had the speakers they were gonna smuggle
in somehow and they were they were
coming in they're heterosexual cisgender
uniforms they're gonna make their way
into the crowd and disrupt it and uh so
i was quite prepared for that and then
you know we get to the event
um
and it's uh it's a it's a great event
it's a big big crowd you know i think we
had over 500 people which is great it's
not all that long ago that i would do
events and there'd be like 20 people in
the crowd so this is a little bit of a
change there the thing is people
uh
people will ask me how do you get
nervous speaking in front of large
crowds no the problem is small crowds
okay you want to know what what nerves
are like
awkwardness when delivering a speech um
be in a large room with like 20 people
and a lot of empty seats that's that's
the problem fill all the seats and
there's no problem at all i can speak in
front of ten thousand people no i'd
rather speak in front of ten thousand
and ten actually
um
so that was all that was all great and
um
you know gave the speech i was waiting
at any moment for the
leftist the trans activists to
initiate their plan and of course they
never did nothing happened at all
much to my disappointment um and then we
finally get to the q a
when as always
you know we're it's if you if you
want to argue with me if you disagree
with my point of view if you want to
debate me if you want to try to
embarrass me
you know
all of the horrible and bigoted things
that i've just said if you want to
point by point rebut and refute and
debunk it you can do that and we
actually at every yaf event people who
disagree are invited to the front of the
of the line um so we're gonna make sure
that you get your chance to say
something and not only did they not
stand up and disrupt the event uh none
of them
got
took the microphone to argue with me
except for one guy which was sort of an
interesting exchange someone who
identified as trans
and
he did and you could watch it if you go
to yaf's youtube channel you could see
the the video the whole speech and then
you can also see the q a and you could
see this interaction
which was interesting and a little bit
confusing
because this guy comes up and and uh he
is i mean i'll say he he is not wearing
the heterosexual uniform um
exactly
and but he gets up there he says he
identifies as trans and but he says he
actually agrees with everything that i
that i said
which i was kind of surprised to hear
and then we kind of started going back
and forth and it became clear through
the conversation that he actually
doesn't agree with me at all
um i think what he was trying to say is
that
is that he doesn't agree with me but he
doesn't but he but he actually after
listening to me doesn't think that i'm a
horrific monster i think that's what he
was trying to get to but i had this back
and forth with him a little bit and um
you know i asked him
uh well do you
do you think that there are because he
was he was accusing me of of
oversimplifying matters and making
things too simple making the issue of
sex and gender too simple and my point
is that no i'm not simplifying it it is
in fact just a simple subject
there are two sexes male and female it's
binary that's it so that's a simple fact
there are a lot of specifics we can get
into when we want to get into the
specifics of the human body and and how
the body works and you know that's
complicated in a certain way
but the fact
of males and females that is simple
and so i asked him if he if he thinks
that uh they're just males and females
in the world or are there other
categories and uh and he said no there's
not just male males and females it's
it's non-binary there are other
categories and i said okay what other
categories are there besides males and
females and he wasn't able to provide
one so we went back and forth and i know
the conversation didn't really go
anywhere because what you what you find
out
and i respect this guy at least for
getting up and getting behind the
microphone because nobody else was
willing to do it on his side
um
but when you find out when you when you
talk to people
who are proponents of gender ideology
it's that they they really just have no
idea what what they think
they have no clue they're they're
totally confused
they they don't even really understand
what their position is supposed to be
and yet they're
never challenged
you know they kind of exist in this
bubble
and no one and it's very easy to
puncture the bubble but no one ever does
it
and so all you have to do is ask very
simple questions and you see you sort of
see their whole worldview shake and and
tumble and crumble
all right
um this is from
yahoo says the nation's relentless
culture wars appear to have taken the
toll even on the nfl with a large number
of republicans saying they have soured
on the league and expressed disapproval
of its efforts to improve the treatment
of black players
there's no there's no bias in the way
this is being presented right
um professional football remains
extremely popular the poll just found
just more than half of american adults
say they regard themselves as fans an
additional 15 percent say they're not
fans but plan to watch the super bowl
uh which will be played on sunday about
but the league's popularity has eroded
somewhat in recent years the poll found
about one-third of those surveyed
nationwide said they are less a fa less
of a fan now than they were five years
ago compared with about uh one in eight
who said they're bigger fans now
the poll can't conclusively say why that
decline has occurred but two questions
about the nfl's handling of issues
involving race provides some strong
hints
people who say they are less of a fan
now than they were five years ago are
more than twice as likely as everyone
else to say the nfl is doing quote too
much to show respect for its black
players
they're also significantly less likely
to approve of the league's rooney rule
which for the last two decades has
required nfl teams to interview minority
candidates for head coaching positions
and certain other high level jobs
so this is um talk about media bias we
you know we had npr and now here's yahoo
or whoever whoever
uh sent this poll around i think it was
los angeles times um yeah los angeles
times
the way the question is framed is um
is the league doing too much to respect
black players
and so apparently a lot of republicans
are answering yes on the poll if you
believe the poll results at all
only because they they know what's
really being asked
so the rooney rule for example
that's that's what that question refers
to is something like that
an affirmative action policy in the nfl
affirmative action in the nfl
in a league that is predominantly black
already
where the vast majority of the
high-paid millionaire famous athletes
are black
60
of the nfl is comprised of black
athletes even though black people are 13
population so massive over
over-representation in the nfl
which is fine
i mean it's fine with me
because i don't think that your job
should be determined by your skin color
why all those uh black players who make
it on those teams and into those
positions why are they there well
because they're really really good
athletes
and that's how they win those positions
but
the problem with the rooney rule
something like that is is it that is it
is it that too much is being done to
respect black people is that the issue
now that's that is what the question is
referring to that's what it's actually
getting at
but that's of course an extremely biased
way of
a
misleading and
absurdly dishonest way of presenting it
the issue isn't that too much is being
done to respect black people
the issue is that a rule like that is
totally unnecessary for one thing
it doesn't actually respect black people
at all
because it treats them as though they
need this extra you know if you were to
analyze people just on the merits they
wouldn't get the job so it's actually
quite disrespectful to the people that
it's supposedly trying to respect
and of course it also disrespects white
people
who are being
specifically excluded by rules like this
so even with the poll being biased in
the way it presents the information uh
the truth is that yeah people are
really tired of having ideology
shoved in their face everywhere they go
and especially in sports this is why it
becomes such an issue in sports is
because this is one place where for
years for decades you know people went
to escape all that it's supposed to be
escapism
um
and when you start putting politics and
ideology even there it becomes even more
frustrating for people
because the whole point is to get away
from that
that's kind of the
the beauty of sports i think or that
should be the beauty of it
it's like you go to um
a stadium you know like i've gone to the
raven stadium in baltimore
and
everybody there
is kind of they're there for the same
reason
and most of people you're fans of the
same team
and there's i talk about all the time
the problem of there being no unity in
this culture because there's nothing to
unite around
well when you're in the stadium for
three hours everyone is uniting around
the fact that they're a fan of this team
it's it's it's silly it's kind of
frivolous
um it's not the kind of unity that you
can build a country around
it once you leave the stadium it kind of
goes away and doesn't matter anymore but
at least for those three hours it's sort
of an escape from everything else and
you're in the you're in the stadium and
you're everyone's focused on this kind
of very simple thing
simple yet entertaining thing
and you can bring your kids there
and it's can be a bonding thing with
your fathers and sons and everything
else
that's what people like sports for and
the fact that's being taken away from
them makes them even more frustrated
you know it's even it's even getting to
me
at this point i mean i'm a huge
football fan as i've said before
and um i've confessed in the past that
uh you know i've i've dumped the nba
they're some you know most hollywood
movies i don't watch anymore i mean all
the i have no problem leaving most of
this stuff behind because i don't want
to be preached to
uh but the nfl was one of the final
things i was kind of holding on to
because i've always been such a big
football fan
and i was trying to block out all of the
the indoctrination all the propaganda
because i just want to watch the game
and this year even me
in this this season i kind of started to
lose interest because it was just it's
just too much
all right this one daley wired says a
christian pastor from utah trended
nationally on social media for hours on
tuesday over a tweet he posted
concerning female modesty
though pastor brian save received much
support from men and women alike he
became a target for outraged feminists
some of whom sent save
racy photos of their breasts and other
body parts
so they were
trying to dunk on this man by sending
naked pictures of themselves
all right um
dear ladies started the tweet that said
off twitter there is no reason
whatsoever for you to post pictures of
yourself in low-cut
shirts bikinis broad underwear or
anything similar ever
not to show your weight loss journey not
to show your newborn baby not to
document your birth story the post the
post is signed off
your brothers
um
people didn't like that to say the least
a mocking dear brian hashtag trended for
hours after the post was published and
numerous male and female feminists
scolded the pastor for having what they
characterized as an unwanted opinion
about female modesty the tweet has been
quote tweeted nearly 20 000 times
here's a taste of the outrage reported
by the blaze
msnbc contributor k fang says i'm a
proud member of the congregation of the
holy church of mind your own damn
business you should try it sometime my
body my choice
well why don't you mind your business
about his opinion
so you what you wear is none of his
business
well his opinion about what you're
wearing is none of your business by that
logic
if you're if you're committed to this
minding your own business thing what do
you care what this guy's tweeting why do
you have to respond to it just his
opinion
he's he's not doing anything to you it's
not harming you
he's not preventing you
from walking around dressing however you
want
if you want to dress like a hussy he's
not he's not he's not physically
preventing you from doing so that's so
you mind your own business
this is always my question to people
anytime you get you get the this
rejoinder of oh why do you care so much
why do you care that i care
i'll turn it right back around on you
if it's silly for me to care how much
sillier sillier is it for you that you
care that i care
because now we have two degrees here
um
pavlovitz who's an anti-trump author and
also claims to be a christian pastor
says pastors like you are why the church
is known for misogyny and the
subjugation of women more than empathy
and equity you should try the sacred
ministry of minding your own damn
business
liberal author tara dublin says dear
brian your invisible sky daddy doesn't
care how you like to do it and neither
does anyone else you repressed weirdo no
one is going to share anything with you
perv please get therapy on how to treat
women as the human beings we are
um and then it goes on from there lots
of other responses now
and and many of the responses we talk
about the incoherence of the left
they're accusing him of being a perv and
he needs to mind his own business and
yet they're also sending him
their naked photos
mind your business you perv here's my
naked photo
now i'm not really interested in the
non-christian
response to this
um
you know the the kind of secular
response
mocking virtue and that kind of thing
uh that that doesn't interest me
i know that's sort of the godless
heathens are going to react this way
to any
promotion of christian virtue
and that's a separate subject and that
is kind of boring and and i don't really
care about that
for me the bigger issue when i was
looking at the reaction to this guy's
tweet about modesty
it's the other christians the other
professed christians
like john pavlovic and there were a lot
of others
many of them claiming to be pastors or
whatever else a lot of people you know
announcing well i'm a christian and i
find this abhorrent
um
a christian pastor talking about modesty
this is this is only scandalous to us
these days in the church as it stands
right now
because many people go to churches where
their pastors never challenge them at
all
their pastors never exhort them to
holiness at all
because that's really what he's talking
about
this is not holier than thou it's not
this is not saying i'm better than you
because that's another thing to keep in
mind that every time someone promotes
virtue
or says hey um here's something that we
should be doing
it's it's not it's not
in and of itself self-righteous or
holier than that
unless they say oh i'm the perfect
example that you all should be following
hey hey everybody you're not acting like
me and you should be follow me as an
example now if somebody says that then
yeah it's holier than now and
self-righteous
but if they simply say uh this
here is the appropriate course of action
that we should be following here's the
appropriate behavior here's what virtue
is and this is what we should be doing
there's nothing self-righteous about
that
and that's what pastors are supposed to
do
so in a way i kind of understand if
you're scandalized by this as a
christian and you go to one of these
churches
where um or you you you allegedly attend
one at least in theory you attend a
church like this maybe you're a member
of one and you go
once every three years or something but
whenever you do show up
and the pastor gets up there and um he
never
says anything about sin
he never challenges you for your own
behavior
he never condemns evil of any kind
he never exhorts anyone to to holiness
and so you've you never encounter this
at all and then you hear a pastor doing
this and you're you're shocked
but i'm here to tell you that this is
what pastors are supposed to do
this is literally their job
there was a time when
every pastor in the church would do this
any time you go to church on sunday you
would hear messages like this
you go back 50 years ago and uh
even if there was disagreement on the
subject nobody would be shocked that a
christian pastor is promoting modesty
modesty chastity these are core virtues
should be nothing shocking about it
um
and especially to have christian women
mocking men
who are trying to live with chastity and
and and virtue
because that's part of the message here
right
and again if you're not a christian i
understand you can laugh and smirk at
this all you want but i'm not talking to
you
so this is a mind your own damn business
sort of conversation now
so you can butt out
if you're not in the church and this is
but if you're if you are a christian
then you should know that that one of
our obligations
as um as christians is to guard each
other's hearts it's one of our
obligations it's something we should be
always trying to do
that's that's what it means to to love
each other to love people
it's loving is willing the good of the
other
loving someone is wanting them to be
holy you know it's wanting to help them
towards holiness
and that's that's one of the big reasons
why we're supposed to exercise modesty
and not just in dress either
okay um you know for example
if you have a lot of money
and you go out of your way to show off
your your money and you're driving
around in a really gaudy car and you're
just whatever you're constantly showing
off how much money you have
well that is immodest
it's also sinful
and for the same reason
largely
in this case you're not you're not
you're not guarding
your brother or your sister's heart
because what you're doing is you're
causing people to feel envy and uh and
that's what you're doing it
intentionally
you want them to be envious of you
you're trying to get them to tumble into
sin
which is a bad thing as a christian
and that's this pastor's point
is that just like you should not be
trying to make your fellow christians
envious
you also shouldn't be trying to make to
um you know to uh foster
feelings of lust or anything like that
um
but i think part of the problem here
also is that
you know
many women
men and women in in the in our culture
today have they have no understanding of
each other because we've been told that
men and women are exactly the same
and so women who've bought into this is
what they think that men are exactly the
same as them
and so they don't understand men they
don't understand male sexuality
they don't understand how sort of visual
men are
um because they just assume that well
men are just like me
and they hear a message like this and
they find it absurd
and finally one other point here
imagine a bunch of men
sending nude and semi-nude photos to a
woman on twitter in order to get back at
her for some opinion that she expressed
imagine that happening i mean what's
what's the story there if that happens
the story is that this person is being
horribly sexually harassed and
everything else
and so here's the um here's even more of
the incoherence because while we're told
that men and women are exactly the same
and for the most part people have bought
into that delusional idea still
you know
if i were to suggest
that this pastor is being sexually
harassed by women who are sending new
photos to them you know people would
laugh at that idea
even the people who say that men and
women are exactly the same and should be
treated the same they'll laugh at it
because that's ridiculous men can't be
sexually harassed
oh really
because if we reverse the roles here
everybody would agree that it's sexual
harassment
all right
are men and women the same or not
you know
is the question
let's uh let's go from page six it says
adele is being accused of transphobia
for declaring at a woke gender-neutral
awards show that she loves being a woman
um
this is uh the rolling the deep singer
made the remark at tuesday's brit awards
that she collected the prize for artist
of the year a newly created category
merging the old best male and best
female artist awards
so they made sure to make the awards
gender neutral now there's no best male
and best female and why because males
and females don't exist and then she
wins the award and she gets up there and
she commits the grave sin
of of talking about the fact that she is
a woman and we have that clip listen to
this
the name of this award has changed but i
really love being a woman and being a
female artist i do
i do
i'm really proud of us i really really
am thank you so much
that is transphobia because as a woman
now
you're not allowed to acknowledge
that you are a woman
and you're especially not to not not
permitted to
be grateful for the fact that you're
willing you're not allowed to have any
positive feelings about the fact that
you're a
woman and so she's being she is she is
she is actually this is a this is a
thing that she is being condemned for
transphobia because of what you just
heard there
and as far as i know adele has not uh
as far as i know she hasn't responded to
this controversy yet
uh other people have spoken up on on her
behalf
but uh she has she has not said anything
and if this madness is ever going to end
then we need people like adele to speak
up
she doesn't want to say anything in
response to it
but she certainly knows how ridiculous
this is
and if if if the word misogyny means
anything
then how could it not apply to this
how is that not
you're not you're not allowed to talk
about the fact that you're a woman you
are not allowed to say i'm grateful to
be a woman
we need people like adele just like jk
rowling has
to speak up about about this because she
knows that it's ridiculous
and it's not going to stop until people
like her
you know it's one thing for people like
me people on the right people who are
expected to have these views it's one
thing for us to go out and ranting and
raving about it which we have to do
but uh we need people who are in the
mainstream like jk rowling she can't be
the only one
because all of them know how crazy it is
and if there's going to be a change
that's going to happen with with them
all right finally we haven't played a
woke tick tock video in a little while
so here's a here's a good one watch this
so this is just one example of thin
privilege
and an example of how hard it is for
women of size to find anything to wear
you see all these racks upon racks of
straight sized clothing
tons of options and then for plus-sized
women you have about six racks
and even then you have limited sizing we
need to do better
so there we go thin
thin privilege um and also i i love the
the phrase
women of size
uh which makes about as much sense as
people of color you know people of color
people of size
well here's the problem is that um
everybody has a size
like if you if you exist then you have
some sort of size so we're all people of
size and we and we all also have a color
you know i'm actually i am not if you if
you look at me i i may appear to be pale
but i do have a color
i'm not some sort of like translucent
ghost sitting here despite appearances
at times
so thin privilege which is uh part of
part of the story here of people looking
desperately for problems in their lives
looking desperately to be victimized
and this is not quite as absurd as
resorting to emojis to find your source
of victimization but it's almost there
that we know
if you're if you're plus-sized there are
options for you
that's kind of the funny thing is she
goes over and she shows oh look at there
there are no options for plus-size women
what i mean there's a whole section
there there's plenty of options
and but if if you want more options then
another way of looking at it is to well
you could lose some weight
it could be an incentive to lose weight
which would be a good thing because it's
going to be healthier for you and you'll
live longer
just a just a suggestion
let's get now to the comment section
[Music]
[Music]
centurion la flam
la flame says i think on a level his
apologies talking about joe rogan aren't
necessarily to any specific person but
an act more for himself it's an act of
humility and justice to say what you've
done
uh that you think is wrong it could be
unwise timing wise but i respect it on a
moral level
yeah well a couple things first of all
in a perfect world in a sort of ideal
society
all things being equal you know it
wouldn't be a problem with someone
offering
an apology a public apology at worst it
would be sort of useless but there
wouldn't be any real problem with it
but we don't live in that society
and so as i've tried to explain many
times you know the
the the biggest problem with the public
apology is that you are it's the food
right it's the it's the fuel
that sustains the outrage mob and you
are feeding it this is what they want
this is what they need not because
they're interested in reconciliation not
because they want to forgive you not
because they're worried about your moral
betterment but because um to them the
apology is is submission it's surrender
um it's kind of their pound of flesh
and it is what sustains them and fuels
them and ensures that they're going to
go off to the next person and the next
person the next person after that
you know when you stop apologizing you
deprive them of oxygen
you deprive them of the fuel that they
need
so that's one point the other point is
yeah um if you think you did something
that was wrong
or if you have something in your past
that comes to light and and you're
embarrassed about it well
you can you can acknowledge
that it was wrong without apologizing
so i'm not arguing
that
um if you if the canceled mob comes
after you for something that you have to
stand by
and defend
everything you've ever done you know
they go digging for something deep in
your past and they find something and
say look at this thing that you did or
said or whatever
um
[Music]
you don't have to just despite them say
oh yeah i'll defend that i was right to
do that that's not the point
so
you can acknowledge that something was
stupid or wrong or whatever
if it was
because the other thing you don't want
them to do you don't want them to
goad you into defending something that
that you know you don't want to defend
or that's indefensible um
but you can do that without apologizing
because who are you apologizing to is
always the question
so when's when when they dig up this
thing on joe rogan right they've combed
through
uh
thousands of hours of podcasts over the
course of 13 or 14 years and they find
examples of him using bad language
and they said do you what are you going
to stand by this
his response could be well look do you
stand by everything you've ever said in
your life
i i know i don't stand by it any more
than you stand by everything you've ever
said
do i apologize to it well who am i
apologizing to you show me who i'm
supposed to apologize to and i'll think
about it i'm not going to apologize to
you the mob you're not hurt by this
um
let's see
devin says matt rogan said directly to
only apologize if you regret something
it can be a political hit job and still
have rogan have regrets about what was
shown
rogan is letting people know that he
doesn't use the word regardless of
context now so the apology is to anyone
that agrees with his current view on the
world
to let them know where he now stands
well once again that's not
okay you can you can even express regret
about something without it being an
apology
so the apologies to anyone who agrees
with his current view on the word what
why do they need an apology i agree with
his current view on the on the word i
suppose but but uh
uh
you know
in the sense that
i agree that people shouldn't use racial
slurs
any racial slur
no matter who the who the targeted group
is
so if that's joe rogan's view on that
word then i agree with it
i think most people do
does that mean that i mowed an apology
for him
because he used the word in the past
no it's ridiculous
z zavon says matt since you asked
um crack pipes at least everywhere i
know of anyway are about a buck
literally a single dollar
and then the chore which is just chore
boy kitchen scrubbers lol or another
dollar
but the chore
so it's like two bucks total
and almost no one is out there catching
diseases or anything like that from used
pipes there is literally no excuse or
reason for any of this
um okay i and this this is not the only
person who who did contact me with
information about uh about crack and
crack pipes maybe i should just be clear
that it's it's i wasn't looking for this
in some some of the information i had
people emailing me with like very
specific information on the pricing of
crack pipes and i i wasn't just to
clarify i was not asking for my own
personal
benefit
but it is a question that i have when we
hear the the byte administration needs
to fund
crack pipes
even putting aside how fundamentally
insane that is
it's like what can could people not
afford to buy a crack pipe even a
crackhead they can't afford that
how expensive can it be apparently
they're just a dollar
so you can run down to your local dollar
store go to dollar tree and uh you know
get a pack of five crack pipes for for
five bucks
uh finally scott says how to escape an
escape room step one promote your
best-selling lgbt lgbt children's book
johnny the walrus four times step two
start eating frosted mini wheats step
three let claven do literally everything
um yeah we did do you know the shut-in
is premiering tonight and we had a
shut-in themed escape room that we uh
that we did
and you could find that
video on daily wires youtube
uh and um you can see in that video that
i do absolutely nothing at all
including i make almost no effort to
make the video itself entertaining but i
did warn them about that ahead of time
this is the second time i've been roped
into doing an escape room and each time
i tell like i'm terrible at them i'm not
gonna do anything i'm not gonna be any
help at all
i won't even make this entertaining i'm
just gonna like wander around
and that's it
and for some reason they keep roping me
into this i don't get it but you can go
watch the video tonight is the knights
for the daily wire why because not only
is it the world premiere of our first
original film shut-in but we'll also be
releasing two new teaser trailers for
new movies coming this year we could be
more excited to be making good on our
promise of bringing you real
entertainment and we seriously hope that
you tune in shut-in is a tale of
redemption and an intense suspenseful
thriller that delivers riveting action
without missing a beat check out the
trailer
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
jessica
i can smell the weakness from here
let me out please
what good is this doing now
your daughter
she's very pretty
[Music]
[Music]
the film premieres tonight february 10th
at 9 pm easter 8 pm central over at
daily wire youtube after this month's
episode of backstage make sure you click
the link in the description and turn on
the notification bell so you don't miss
it now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
so today we canceled dr susie diembo who
uh you may remember as the mulleted
communications professor who appeared on
my episode of dr phil she has been quite
silent publicly ever since that episode
aired probably because she embarrassed
herself to such an unfortunate degree in
fact she embarrassed herself even more
than viewers of the show realized
because her worst moments were left on
the cutting room floor which she should
be grateful for
well now she's back this time on dr
phil's podcast to reflect on that
experience and also to explain why i'm
such a horrible and wrong and evil
person now you notice how she waits
until i'm 3 000 miles away before she
tries to make this case with with me
safely out of the the room and out of
the state
she can launch her missiles
which she does throughout the course of
an hour-long interview we'll play just a
few clips starting with this piece from
the beginning of the discussion listen
to this
why is this such a divisive issue
because i think it is a divisive issue
yeah no i think you're totally right and
and it's good to talk about this example
in addition to what you said because
it's an example of how i
approach communication and conflict in
general
um
it it's
well there's at least two reasons it's
divisive uh first you have people like
matt walsh and his team
capitalizing and exploiting the very
real uncertainty that people can feel
and face when there is a culture change
like this
for me i think it makes total sense to
have people
be um fearful around something like
gender pronouns um or personal pronouns
and uh to feel
anxiety
uh when they learn about that uh because
it can question their fundamental core
beliefs
so this is an example of how she
approaches
communication and conflict she says she
approaches communication and conflict
by waiting three weeks to come up with
any kind of counter argument to someone
and then at that point presenting the
counter argument um
while the other person is out of the
room
that's her communication and conflict
resolution strategy as someone who is an
expert in the field
she also again as a communications
expert
immediately attacks her opponent's
perceived motivations
rather than addressing the actual
arguments
and you're gonna you're gonna notice
that throughout the into all the clips
we play is that that's all she does is
go after what she perceives to be my
motivation while saying nothing about
the arguments that i presented
in this case she says that i'm
exploitative
i'm exploiting the fear that people feel
when they quote learn about personal
pronouns because this new information is
causing them to quote question their
core beliefs
okay well first of all nobody is
learning about personal pronouns for the
first time
no one learned about pronouns from dr
phil
no one is learning about pronouns from
the you know the the gender ideologues
we already knew about that
we aren't confused by pronouns or afraid
of them
we're all quite familiar with the
concept it is you susie who are confused
see you think that words are your little
pets
which you can
take personal ownership of
and you think that the meaning of words
is entirely subjective that each person
can make up their own meaning as they go
along but what you don't understand as a
communications professor is that if
language is entirely subjective
if there's no set definition for these
words then communication is impossible
because literally the whole point of
language has just been removed causing
communication to collapse and break down
you know there has to be a shared
understanding of what the words mean
or
there's no way to convey meaning to
anybody
if we all have our own meaning for the
words that we're using
so when you say that a man is a she
and i ask you what do you mean by that
how is that person a she and you have no
answer for that question you have made
communication impossible because you are
using words apart from their objective
meaning without any idea of what your
new meaning even is
you have not put anything forward
that causes anyone to question their
core beliefs at no point have you or
anyone on your side or anyone who pushes
gender ideology ever said anything
that makes someone go wow that's a great
point i never thought of it like that
sending them into some kind of
existential crisis where they begin to
reanalyze everything they thought they
knew this has never happened
because nothing that you say means
anything
if you're causing people to question
their core beliefs it's not by
presenting arguments but it's by
berating and cajoling and threatening
and coercing them
into giving up their core beliefs
out of fear of social alienation and
shame
so then so then who exactly is
exploiting fear in this case
let's uh listen to the next clip
and it's really frustrating to me too
especially around the
you know the the pronoun episode and
that react the reaction that people had
to that
so you
you laying out uh the how vast your
audience is means you are the perfect
platform to present multiple viewpoints
uh in my view because you're reaching
the most people um
and
you the way
we need to hear
both of the or both many different sides
of an issue so that people can make a
decision for themselves and when we shut
down people from or from hearing other
kinds of perspectives it's just uh
productive to me and it's really boring
and uh it's usually motivated by uh
the need for validation from one side
that's not uh genuine in my view i mean
i could go on and on about this uh
especially with regard to our episode
but
um
i don't agree i mean i think that
providing that platform is a good thing
some on that on your show i wonder if
maybe i didn't do my job well enough
because they think that he won
and i was like
i didn't think that
yeah well you i mean you said it there
not me if if if it makes you feel better
susie
you did have an impossible job um you
did lose you know the argument but your
job was to defend and legitimize
something that is fundamentally
incoherent there's no way to do that
there's no way to win that argument the
only way that you win is if the other
side surrenders ahead of time
and that's what you've come to expect
from these conversations because it's
what most people do
it didn't happen in our case and that's
why you were so flustered
she said in the earlier clip that when
she's talking to her students especially
those from rural areas and introducing
the gender pronoun concept to them that
she's introducing something that they've
never heard before
you know but that's not true as we
covered everyone has heard of pronouns
before
and the more familiar you are with the
concept and with the rules of grammar
generally the more impervious you are to
the nonsense that people like susie and
her ilk spew on the subject
but speaking of people being introduced
to things for the first time it is susie
and the people on her side who have
literally never been challenged on their
views by anyone ever in their lives
that's why they collapse so easily
that's why they run away claiming that
they've been traumatized
people on my side
we've all this is the advantage that we
have
we've all heard and confronted gender
ideology a million times we can't escape
it
so you can't surprise us we've heard all
of it we hear we hear all of this every
day
everywhere we go how could we not it's
everywhere there is no bubble available
where you can go inside it and escape
this nonsense
but these people they all live in
bubbles where the opposing side does not
exist that's actually available to them
that's an option
most of the time
and that's why they're so unprepared to
deal with challenges
the reason people thought that i won the
argument is because well because i won
it
but i won it simply because i asked
questions about the opposing side's
position
which nobody on the opposing side could
answer because
they've never been asked those questions
before
because for most of them on that stage
and most of them generally it's probably
like the first time they've ever even
had a conversation with someone who
disagrees with
them let's uh let's listen to one more
clip here
you did a good thing by i didn't really
know who matt walsh was uh that well
before i went on the show but i'm real
glad that i did that and that you had
him on because
people need to hear
the what he is talking about now my
dilemma and i've been thinking about
this since the show and i don't know
that i'll have a concrete answer for you
yet but it's been on my mind is how i
think it's important to have him on and
um
i wish uh he does they don't play fair
he's not playing fair he's yelling and
and uh
so i've been try sorting through the
dilemma of how to get people to actually
listen to the words he's saying
and with me i don't care if you if
you're conservative thinking or you
don't like personal pronouns it's not
the outcome it's how he got to that
outcome because his argument made no
sense
and it was exploiting fear and it was a
lot of generalizations
um and that's why i feel like you needed
to have him on
so because i want people to hear that
now i don't know that that happened
okay well she wants people to hear my
argument she says well
uh we can agree on that point at least i
want people to hear them too though she
says that i didn't play fair because i
was yelling
except i never yelled at any point
during that episode
and and this is how you know you lost
the argument by the way
if after the fact you're complaining
that your opponent wasn't being fair
it's like i said
at the beginning that this if
once you start complaining about the
refs
you know after the games hey it wasn't
fair this is they missed that call they
should you know that your team lost
now if i had run up and snatched all
their microphones or something and said
ah you can't say anything
that might qualify as not playing fair
that also would have been kind of funny
and i might as well have taken their
microphones because they weren't saying
anything anyway
but far from snatching their microphones
i was actually inviting them to speak
more
by asking them questions about their
position
they could not answer those questions
because their position is fundamentally
incoherent
which is not my fault don't take it out
of me susie
but for now i do have to say
to susie d'ambo that you are once again
cancelled
i'll leave it there for today thanks for
watching thanks for listening have a
great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens production manager pavel
voldowski the show is edited by robbie
dantzler our audio is mixed by mike
coromina hair and makeup is done by
cherokee heart and our production
coordinator is mckenna waters the matte
wall show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2022
[Music]
i'm
so sorry
now
sorry
[Music]
jessica
i can smell the weakness from here
rob
rob
owes me money
let me out
is this doing please
you
had your way
i'm scared
now
you
must pay
your daughter
she's very pretty
[Music]
[Music]
you